cette 33e édition de la course du
printemps a été un cru historique le
record de l'épreuve a été battu par le
vainqueur grégory cheval licenciés a
lieu à saint quentin
il a franchi la ligne après cinquante et
une minutes et 8 secondes de course soit
une moyenne de plus de 17 km heure il
devient par la même occasion champion
des yvelines du 15 km et quelques
quarante deux minutes plus tard guy cad
à pau en termine à son tour de toutes
les éditions
après ce que 76 ans il a bouclé les 15
km en 1h 33 mais pas très content lui
quand même nom dans ces instants de
l'unijambiste sa haine parce que non
j'ai déjà réussi 06 06 donc quand je
vois que je me traîne là sur des
kilomètres bombe est en soi copies bon
bout avec là je pars dans les petites
douleurs chine et où ça fait mal au
genou
je fais tous les jours tous les jours de
la gym et irma de milo
un peu l'alter barre fixe un peu tous
les jours donc qui tire ma colonne
vertébrale max est un art de l'arthrose